okay so a quiet place part one and two
are some of the best horror movies this
side of the millennium the two films
bring a new dimension to the genre and
in the movies we follow the abbott
family as they try and survive in a
world overrun by alien predators that
prey on sound the second film somewhat
fills in where they come from and we
start off with a flashback in which we
catch the meteorite they came to earth
on crashing through our atmosphere the
scene takes place in summer and in the
first film we see that day 473 takes
place on october 3rd because of how
evelyn marks the calendar this means
that the aliens came to earth on june
17th which means that july the 4th was
right around the corner this would
explain why the abbotts had fireworks in
their field as they could have been
about to celebrate independence day or
have taken some from a store in the area
that was stocking them up now speaking
of stores in the opening of a quiet
place too we see lee walking past
brody's pizzeria john krazinski actually
stated that he put this in as a tribute
to the character martin brody aka the
sheriff and jaws jaws is classed as the
monster movie that pretty much pioneered
the summer blockbuster and it's awesome
that krazynski gave a nod to one of the
films that starred at all he also passes
a dog sitting in the back of a truck at
this point and dogs would likely have
all been wiped out due to them having a
tendency to bark this would explain why
we don't see another one in either of
the movies as it'd be too difficult to
train to keep quiet now the town plays
quite a big part in the opening of both
films and in a quiet place too we watch
as leigh enters the pharmacy much like
how his family do in the first film
however you might notice that when lee
opens the door that it closes to the
sound of a ringing bell this is of
course common among shop doors as it
lets the members of staff know when
someone has come in however in a quiet
place part 2 the front doors are held
open so that they can't close and ring
the bell as this would alert the
monsters on its way out lee of course
also passes the rocket ship that his son
would pick up in part one this would
eventually lead to his death and though
it's quite an obvious call back i
thought i'd point it out as it's one of
the most chilling details in the movie
both ian bo were the only two members of
the abbotts to die and thus the two
characters that are killed from the
family are somewhat linked in this shot
now in part two we see that the shelves
and the pharmacy are pretty well stocked
however by the start of the first film
most of them have been picked dry this
is except for the chip isle which we see
reagan walking down i know we guys call
them crisps and not chips but with this
movie being set in america i thought i'd
stick to the terms you guys use but i'll
always call them crisps shout out gary
lineker now chips are of course
extremely noisy when you open them and
they're even louder when you sit down
and snack on them whilst people are sat
trying to watch a quiet place but you
won't shut the hell up i'm talking to
you steven that's all right i'm talking
to you now the survival of the family in
both films of course relies on them
keeping quiet and there are some subtle
details hidden in there that show how
they've adapted to live in this
noise-free world now what i love about
the first movie especially is that we do
see them having somewhat a sense of
normality due to them listening to music
on headphones having dinner as a family
and the kids also end up getting
homeschooled what the abbotts have had
to do though is completely remove all
semblance of noise from their lives and
this is seen in a number of ways they of
course walk barefoot everywhere and have
placed sand on the typical paths that
they trot on to keep their feet from
making a noise at the dinner table we
also catch that they don't have any
cutlery and even have leaves's plate so
that they don't make any clanging noises
you might also notice that there are
candles lighting the table and
throughout the movie we can catch them
at several points lee even nurses over
evelyn and attention is drawn to the
candle in this scene you might even
notice that there's a lamp beside lee
and that this is off might seem a bit
weird to use candles when they have
electricity but this is actually because
light bulbs can sometimes emit a noise
we also know that the aliens can
interfere with electrical devices and
thus the best thing to do is use things
that don't rely on currents unless
absolutely necessary most of the light
bulbs that show up at the farm are the
classic white ones whereas we do see
later that red is used to signal that
evelyn is going into labor red light
bulbs actually tend to emit a slight hum
when they're turned on and this would
somewhat attract the monsters to them
instead of the farmhouse so the lights
going on at this point would not only
let lee know that evelyn is going into
labor but it would also draw the
creatures away if needs be that's
science yeah that's science at the
channel now this happens just as evelyn
is about to give birth and speaking of
giving birth if you're watching this
video then it means that my wife is now
in hospital giving birth to our twin
boys i've been saving this breakdown for
a couple of weeks so that i had
something to drop when i can't post one
and we'd massively appreciate the thumbs
up yeah look at this guy using the birth
of his kids to get likes yeah it's a bit
scummy isn't it but i thought i'd just
explain why i'm doing a quiet place
breakdown and not whatever is out now
also yeah if you subscribe i'll name one
of my kids after you so it's a win-win
anyway the baby plays a big part in both
films and dealing with the screaming
torment that i'm going to be subjected
to for the next couple of years is
something that the abbotts have to plan
for they do several things in their home
to make sure that it's baby proofed and
that the child is as noise free as
possible we see at one point that evelyn
creates a mobile to hang above the
baby's crib and you might notice that
all the things attached to it are soft
toys sometimes mobiles jangle but
everything that could possibly make a
sound has been removed as marcus enters
the building where the baby's room is
you might also notice that a mattress is
slumped to the side and this is instead
of a hatch of something on hinges as
that could potentially creak whilst we
visit boa bits grave later on there are
photos on it but these have pins holding
them in place instead of nails nails
would of course have to be hammered in
whereas you can push your pin in with
your bare hands without making a sound
evelyn later hangs clothes up on a
washing line as a dryer would make a
noise and though that's an obvious one
it shows how much thought the creative
team put into how the abbotts would have
to live this extends to what they eat as
well during one scene we see evelyn
pulling fish out of a steam oven which
is of course quieter than an electrical
gas one however beyond that fish are
actually pretty much the only type of
animal that the abbotts could eat though
they on a farm pigs chickens cows and
sheep all make noises like their singing
old macdonald and therefore they
couldn't be kept around that makes sense
as to why lee and marcus go fishing in
the movie because fish of course don't
vocalize or have a noise that they can
make in part two we also see that aliens
can't swim meaning that fish won't be
hunted by them either as if they did
make a noise the monsters would drown
trying to get to them because of this
fish might even be some of the only
animals on earth left alive in the wake
of their invasion because their habitat
is extremely dangerous to the creatures
we can also actually at one point
sparking up a lighter inside of his
jacket this is done for a number of
reasons as not only does it stop the
wind from potentially putting out the
flame but it also masks the sound that
sparking it up would cause now the
character does this to create a fire
which acts as a beacon that we see the
other survivors also doing this plays a
big part in the second film when the
abbotts travel out to me emmett played
by killian murphy they hear a broadcast
of the song beyond the sea by bobby
darin which has featured in a number of
films tv shows and games this includes
the x-files episode titled the same name
bioshock and also goodfellas in it bobby
sings about the love of his life waiting
beyond the sea and how his life will be
so much better there this carries
somewhat of a double meaning for the
film as the characters will find a
sanctuary and the name of the song of
course will guide them there at one
point regan brings out a map as well as
an address book with the radio station
on it if you look closely you'll see
that it's based at nostromo avenue and
nostromo is the name of the ship in the
first alien movie the monsters in this
of course share a lot of similarities
with the xenomorphs so this is a really
nice nod to the franchise krazynski also
put a cool little callback on the map in
this scene and we can catch stamford
connecticut there as well if you've seen
the office and you'll know that his
character jim halpert transferred there
during one of the seasons and the
director put this in intentionally as
the show was his big break it has a
deeper layer to it though as stamford
was the place that jim went off and did
something else much like how krazynski
has with these films anyway that wraps
up the breakdown and of course love to
hear if there's any easter eggs that we
missed i'll probably not be reading them
as i'll have my hands full but other
people will in the comments and they'll
think you're much smarter than i am so
congratulations yeah you've already
disappointed me in front of my kids now
if you want something else to watch we
have a video linked on screen right now
that i'm sure you'll love so head over
there right after this without the way
thank you for seeing through this one i
hope you have an awesome weekend take
care yourself peace